[Music]
I'm Montana I work at the machine
learning platform at instacart part of
our mission is to build a firm
foundation for all of our data
scientists to create the most
sophisticated models they can possibly
conceive so that those deliver value
back to our customers our retailers our
shoppers and our CPG partners the other
big part of our mission is to empower
our normal software engineers or data
engineers to leverage machine learning
in their organization without
necessarily having all of the expertise
that our data scientists have when it
comes to sophisticated modeling so the
way this plays out in practice is mostly
what this talk will be about I'll spend
ten minutes in the beginning explaining
high level machine learning concepts for
the data engineers in the room that may
not be familiar before we go into any of
that I'll just tell you about a little
bit about instacart so you understand
why we care about data why we care about
data science machine learning and data
engineering our core value prop is that
we deliver groceries in as little as an
hour from the stores that you love we
connect customers to a personal shopper
that deliver the service directly to the
customer in real time we partner with
local retailers to give the customers
access to stores they are familiar with
and also that they trust
we also offer coupons and other
incentives from CPGs product
manufacturers for people not in the
industry they can increase the value of
our proposition back to the customer the
customer experience this begins by them
choosing a store we partner with
hundreds of retailers throughout the
country to give them the largest lection
possible they'll select the groceries
that they want from that retailers
warehouse they'll build their shopping
cart they'll check out and choose a
delivery time in as little as an hour
and then we'll deliver those products to
their door from the shopper side of the
equation the shopper will get a
notification there's a delivery
available to
they will choose to accept that they
will go into the store they will shop
for all of the items they will scan each
item so that they get strong
verification signals they can also
replace items if it's out of stock
eventually they'll check out with an
insta cart credit card at the retailer
and then they'll deliver those goods to
the customer one of the key ways we use
machine learning and instacart is on our
search and discovery team this is
probably the most familiar part of the
product to anybody who has used service
we we use supervised learning in several
different examples this is probably the
most prominent form of machine learning
in the industry right now that's
currently delivering real value the when
it comes to pure text matching on search
results it's often not going to be good
enough when you have subtle differences
like milk milk chocolate or chocolate
milk that need vastly different search
results the way we improve this is to
see what what features are in these
products we break every product down by
its features what what is the brand of
the product what is the fat content is
it organic is it pasteurized homogenized
how big is it
where was it made we can go all the way
down to the dominant color in the image
to see what exactly represents this
product we're going to encode all of
this information numerically
additionally the fact that some of these
products are missing information becomes
important when it comes to ultimate
search result quality if something
doesn't have an image it's probably much
less appealing to a customer and so that
kind of gap in the data is actually a
really big information signal when it
comes to machine learning it takes a lot
of domain expertise to understand all of
these features and their relevance to
customers which is why we embed all of
our data scientists and machine learning
engineers directly into small teams with
product managers working closely
together on a day to day basis we don't
have a centralized machine learning or
data science or data inch team
every product in our catalogue shares a
set of come on right side I think I got
a slide behind I'm sorry guys when we
talk about an individual feature the key
to successfully designing these features
is translating our human understanding
to numeric values we call this encoding
for example colors are continuous from
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet we can number those one through
seven software engineers of standardized
on more than 16 million colors between
red and violet so computer can tell you
with much greater precision what color
this milk is than I can I would just
call it cream every time a customer
searches for milk and adds a product to
their cart they give an instant dozens
of training examples they tell us the
one product they added to their cart is
milk and all the other products we
showed them are not a match for milk not
everyone agrees on what the best match
for milk is on instacart but this is
where machine learning really shines the
features of each product are what's
important not any one example the model
will be trained to understand which
features are statistically Milky and
which are not
homogenized pasteurized grade-a are all
important from up to half keeping in
mind that the model will also be trained
with orange juice which can be
pasteurized but it's often not
homogenized so machine learning models
consider dozens of features holistically
before they make a single decision when
we see new products from new retailers
at new stores we can instantly serve
great search results because our models
have learned to generalize from
individual features not the products
themselves we can scale our catalog
faster and more accurately than trying
to hand label all of the products in the
world once you move to a numeric model
of the world you unlock all sorts of
functionality also you should show you
some of the ways we build on what our
machines learn from search one of the
deep learning superpowers that we have
is called transfer learning we can use
something learned in the previous model
about what makes a good search result
for milk all of these products we can
transfer that to a help
predictions on a news task in this case
we want to find which products are
competitive in our catalog so we can
help our customers find them together
just like they do in brick-and-mortar
stores Coke and Pepsi are very similar
numerically in a search for Cola but it
turns out very few people add both of
them to the cart at the same time that
signal that some products are similar or
rarely purchased together allows us to
merchandise them as competitive with
each other we can apply this same model
the opposite direction and we can say
that when people buy peanut butter they
often buy jelly and so we see the
merchandising opportunity there as a
complementary instead of competitive
product that's very quick look at what
machine learning is and how it can be
used to improve say a storefront I want
to talk to you about a product project
that's more top of mind for me right now
which is actually building the
open-source library that we use on a day
to day basis we're using it now
throughout the org four out of four of
our different data science teams are
using it on all of their newest projects
we still have a large number of legacy
models that are being deployed with
various bespoke techniques that we've
developed over the last five years but
moving forward we'd like to standardize
how we develop and design models so and
the really interesting thing here is
that as we've taken our experience from
building models by professionals who
have had you know dozens of years of
industry experience combined from
different organizations we can boil
those down into the set of best
practices and what a typical model looks
like what its lifecycle is how we want
to deploy those how we want to maintain
those how we need to build those that's
going to work more or less generically
and universally in this specialized
supervised learning case so there is
that caveat this is a fairly complicated
slide we're going to break it down piece
by piece and walk through it and I'm
gonna put code up on the slideshow
because that's the language I really
like
so that we can break it down into a
step-by-step process of building and
deploying a model into production at
instacart lor is the name of the project
it's available on pi PI as a pip package
you can pip install it that's always the
first step it's it's similar in its
command line conventions to Rails
instacart is a rails shop so if you've
ever done web development you can call
rails new you'll generate this big
framework dump of a directory inside
your your github repo and and so a lot
of a lot of the thinking of convention
over configuration of simplicity of ease
of use of being opinionated about
certain things that there are a hundred
different options and most of them are
good most of them have trade-offs we saw
earlier benchmarks between snowflake
redshift and bigquery does it really
matter
maybe but ease of use is what we want to
solve for most of the time we want to
solve for developer productivity so
though the way you create a new machine
learning project at instacart which may
be used for a single model but often
time they're used for a whole family of
models like we just saw in the search
example when you have one model very
quickly you'll start to find all of
these other applications where you want
very similar combinations of features
slightly different objective functions
as a result and so keeping all that code
together in the same project really
enables us to reuse and create more
modular testable systems the first
command here like I said was you install
the lor package that will give you a
command line application you can lower
in it a new project and that will give
you a directory with a base skeleton
that's deployable on Heroku you can use
a Heroku build pack to deploy these
things into production you can wrap them
up in a docker file if you want and
basically all that means is you'll get
an empty flask app running nothing
because we haven't actually created a
model yet the third command here at the
dollar sign is to generate a scaffold
and what we're going to
to predict is when delivery is created
three or four months later occasionally
you know we'll have somebody call this
up and say hey I never did that and
they'll they'll issue a credit card
dispute on their credit card so this is
a very costly thing when it happens to
instacart even though it's an incredibly
rare event which makes it a very
difficult machine learning problem and
it's a very important problem to solve
is to know if is this delivery a
legitimate delivery is are the features
that we have the signals that you have
at the time the customer checks out
before we've paid you know for $200 in
groceries and spent an hour driving it
over to their house is this the person's
credit card do we actually have a
legitimate transaction taking place here
and I think you'll see machine-learning
deployed pretty broadly across all types
of fraud detection in the industry so
what we're doing here is adding a
regression parameter to the scaffold so
we're going to generate a regression
model if you if you want to think about
supervised learning models there are
broadly two types they're classification
where you're trying to predict is it a B
or C and then there's regression where
you're predicting a continuous value a
numeric value so 0 to infinity or
negative infinity to positive infinity a
lot of people will bound it from 0 to 1
so regression is predicting a continuous
range of numbers category or categorical
or binary categorization or multiple
classification these have specific
discrete buckets that you're trying to
predict things in we could frame this
problem as a binary classification true
or false we can frame it as a regression
probabilistic problem of from 0 to 1 how
likely is it to be fraud so 0 being
there's no chance one being there's a
hundred percent chance of it being fraud
the data scientists will have opinions
about which of these is the appropriate
technique true or false
your product manager will have opinions
about do they want to true or false or
do they want a sliding scale of 0 to 100
mm-hmm so this is actually a very
important design decision on what you're
going to do with your machine learning
model it's why it's it's escalated all
the way to the command
there's a lot more command-line
parameters you can add if you want you
don't have to generate the full scaffold
if you don't want if you just want to
generate any single one of these things
we'll go ahead and talk about what all
of the types of things that are being
generated are for now I'm gonna gloss
over the six files that come out other
than to point out there's some tests
there's some ipython notebooks which
anybody who's done data science should
be familiar with and then there's three
Python classes that are generated we'll
start with the data source and create an
extract everybody who's at in data
engineering is familiar with ETL
processes this is strictly an extract it
typically looks like a sequel file in
our case we're only going to have one
feature and the very first version of
our model for to keep this short so that
we don't make it a happy hour in this
case we're going to look at the visitors
IP address what is the latitude and the
longitude that they had the delivery
delivered to and then we have the truth
the training of was this credit card
charge actually disputed within some
time frame so we can actually measure
the distance between the we can geo
locate the IP address and then we can
measure the distance between that IP
address and where the delivery address
is and see is this person actually at
the place that they're having it
delivered room are they in you know
Russia or just testing fake credit card
numbers to see if they can find some new
way to scam us that's a pretty quick
query but you'll notice that it's
actually going to return every delivery
from all time we'll run run this against
our data warehouse redshift something
that actors no actually handle that kind
of load and then we're basically pulling
that entire table into memory for these
four columns
the the next step in the pipeline will
be to run that data into a cache and
then to split it apart it's very
important when you do machine learning
that you you want your training data but
you also want to other sets of data
split out of that you want your
validation data which you'll use pretty
soon and then you want your test data
the reason you split those out is
because you don't want your algorithm to
get to peek at the answers that you're
going to test it against you're going to
show it a bunch of data let it train on
that
well you've held out some data for later
and then after it thinks it knows the
right answers you use that data to test
it again and we'll actually have two
different test phases in many of our
machine learning models one is an
iterative test that you go through
continuously and you constantly try and
optimize your machine learning against
that data set if you do that though
you're running the risk that you're
optimizing the data set just for that
little thing so after you're all done
once you finally put your stamp of
approval said I'm happy with the results
that I'm getting then you get to
actually use your final test set and
that's your final score that you would
use to say whether you have improved
upon the previous efforts so going going
forward will will actually construct our
pipeline this pipeline is probably not
like most of your data inch pipe lines
this was sort of an overloaded term that
we use in machine learning this pipeline
inherits from the base lower pipeline
class this is a holdout pipeline so it's
going to hold out those two extra slices
of the data set and it has basically one
job which is to return it a data frame
in the get data method its lore is an
object-oriented language so you
typically will inherit from a base class
and then you'll override one or two key
methods or the whole thing if you really
want to get crazy so you can see here
that we're laurio redshift is our pooled
redshift connection that has appropriate
cadential just configured for the
project and the configuration file this
is all available we have very many
connections in law Ryo
we have s3 access we have Postgres
access we have Redis access we
all of these things that our wonderful
data engineers provide to us
pre-configured for our software
engineers and our machine learning
engineers to access with a single
function call data frame returns a
panda's data frame if you're familiar
with Python
it's basically and then in memory table
you can perform many of the sequel like
operations we're used to in highly
efficient manner an interesting caveat
it is is that its columnar similar to
our data warehouses it's not row
oriented so your operations should be
you should just keep that in mind when
you're working with it the final thing
to keep in mind is that we're using the
sequel file here that we created
previously and we're going to cache that
you don't have to cache if you don't
want to but I like caching and the next
step is to actually take all of the raw
data that we had and we had an IP
address and two different allonge and
then the final answer and what we
actually wanted to calculate was the
distance between that IP address and the
that and the launch so this is a bit of
a contrived example but these are
encoders inside of lor back inside our
pipeline we're going to define a second
function and it returns the encoders
that are appropriate that we actually
want to use to construct the features
for our machine learning model so in
this case what we've said is that we
want to calculate the distance between
these two the latitude and the longitude
and then we're going to use the GI geoip
transformer on the IP address to get
this latitude another transformer on the
IP address to get the longitude all of
those will be in input 2 the distance
transformer norm is the actual encoder
the difference between encoders and
transformers is that encoders are
stateful transformers are not
transformers or pure functions so they
don't need any memory they don't need to
have ever seen anything any data like
this data to know the on the other hand
machine learning models particularly
deep learning models they don't like
very large numbers if you pass it 10,000
in one feature and your other feature
only is between 0 and 1 the 0 to 10,000
feature can completely dominate and
swamp the other feature
so what norm does
is it looks at all of the values in that
feature and it divides it by the average
and the standard deviation
I'm sorry subtract the average and
divides by the standard deviation so
that you get a small number around 0 to
1 throughout for most of your inputs
which is nice for most machine learning
so but of course that's stateful and
it's dependent on that particular model
so this is something that we have to
keep track of for all time now because
during the training data we learned what
the average and the standard deviation
of this was and so we have to now save
that with the model and keep that going
forward so that any new data that we see
later on we can apply the same
transformations and encoding to it for
the the final bit we're going to get the
output the output is this disputed
column that we want to predict whether
this delivery will be eventually a
credit card dispute we're going to use
the pass encoder on it which simply says
take the value I'm giving you it's
basically a no op because we like the
fact that this is already a boolean from
the database it's already 0 to 1 once we
got that that's basically the end of our
pipeline
Laure will take care of doing pretty
much all of the rest to finish our model
we need to inherit from the base class
that we choose in this class we're going
to use the Charis library which is built
on tensorflow it's a deep learning
library you need to implement the
constructor which basically passes a
pipeline in an estimator you don't
actually need to subclass because all
we're doing is we're creating an
instance of the superclass with these
two parameters so you could just
instantiate the superclass and assign
the pipeline and assign the estimator
that we want to use the estimator that
we're using is a default lor estimator
so we're gonna actually swap out the
binary classifier this is because
halfway through my talk slides I decided
I'd rather use binary classification for
this problem because my product manager
made a last-second change rather than
the regression that I started with so
it's very
important and it's very cool that I can
start with one type of model I can make
a one-line change here after I've
generated my scaffold and I'm not boxed
into a corner or if I'm actually doing
the testing like I should as a good data
scientist then I'll actually be able to
compare well what does it look like if
I'm doing binary classification how many
trues and falses do I get versus if I do
a linear regression how are we going to
actually choose the data point that
decides what action we take you know
maybe it's very likely then we
completely block it if it's some I like
Li we send it to review if it's
moderately likely we just throw up an
error on the website this is our product
manager questions so that that basically
gets us our full model that is a machine
learning model you have all this now you
can then go back to your command line
you can run lower tests you can make
sure you didn't make any typos this will
build the model it will run the sequel
against your test database that you've
already set up make sure that your
sequel actually executes returns rows
it'll take those roads it will feed it
all it's generally very quick as long as
your test database is very quick
hopefully you don't have eight billion
rows in your test database locally on
your laptop but if you did that would be
a pretty exhaustive test those are two
automatic smoke tests generated by the
framework when you generate your model
you can of course write as many unit
tests as you want when you're thinking
about what could break in my data which
is which is actually a very important
practice the the next step of okay great
we've got a piece of software it's on my
laptop that's fantastic I want to deploy
this code to a central server which
instacart uses a mono repo all of our
code is in the same github repository
for the entire organization all our
projects were just in subfolders which
is really interesting in practice it
works surprisingly well because I can
grow up the code base for any string and
I can see who's using any column in the
database or any other features that I'm
interested and in this case I can check
my code in that creates an automatic
deploy it'll go out to a staging server
I can SSH into that staging
server in that case it has the real
redshift connection it has everything
that it needs to be running against
production data I've already tested
locally so I'm not afraid of it breaking
I can then call lore fit which is
another command then I pass it the name
of the model that we just created which
is this loss prevention to predict
delivery disputes it'll go ahead and
fire up it'll start training on as many
samples as it has this is running
against my local laptop database with a
hundred samples it's going to validate
on 10 sec samples ten samples are
invisible here which are being held out
for later testing you can tensorflow is
really cool because it gives you this
ETA on how long each epoch is going to
take you can see this is the loss the
loss is basically the difference between
the predictions it's making and the true
answers it's getting to see during
training so you want this number to go
down over time as you let this thing run
for some number of epochs each pass
through the full data is considered in
the epoch you'll see that the loss will
go down from its initial value that's
very high say 105 it'll get down 2.5 5.5
3.5 to with each epoch it will almost
always continue to go down because over
time the model will start to memorize
more and more of the data because seeing
the state of multiple times so it can
start eventually it can just memorize
the whole thing and then you'll get zero
loss you'll get perfect predictions but
the important part of the validation is
that it has to then go and make
predictions against data that's never
been trained on before so it's got this
second set of data and it starts making
predictions over here and this is what
we're actually looking at this is what
we're actually considering this will
very rarely be better than this and
you'll see this number will come down
over time but eventually this number
will start going up as your model starts
wasting more and more resources on
memorization that don't generalize to
things that it's never seen before and
as soon as that starts going up patience
is a parameter you can pass during
training but you say you can wait maybe
five times or zero times however many
you want as soon as that starts going up
you want to stop training your model
because it's wasting time
once that once you call that that model
is then saved to the model store the
model store is configurable again this
can be an s3 bucket it can be your local
hard drive it can be Redis if that's
where you like to store binary data some
important files that are generated
during this whole process you have your
requirements txt and your runtime txt
runtime is your Python version so that's
just going to have three dot 6.4 or what
or 2.7 Laura's compatible with either
because we have many old data science
projects that nobody wants to port from
2.7 to 3.6 but we're doing everything in
3.6 now requirements txt will be a
completely frozen set of all
requirements that the model was built
with all the way down to the minimum
version of the most dependent package so
that you don't have to worry about if
somebody else checks out your project
will they be able to run your model
because you know flask is upgraded some
minor dependency that's no longer
compatible and they don't know which
version of flask you were using so this
this actually solves a huge class of
problems it's definitely a best practice
for us you've got your database
configuration which you can use
environment variables to interpolate
depending on the system that you're
running in which connections should be
available inside of there it's your
typical Python config file so that's the
any format which just specifies string
name equals connection parameters or you
can go the more verbose route of string
name and then you can say host port IP
user password whatever there's also a
AWS config files there which will take
your I am role things like that if you
use AWS services which we rely on pretty
heavily at instacart you'll notice that
when we cashed the the original get data
response it actually creates this file
on disk which it uses hashing on the
sequel file to generate a unique key at
that point in time for what the sequel
is it dumps all of that into a pickle so
that if you then call that back from the
disk cache you'll you'll get a near
instantaneous result
Pikul is actually surprisingly one of
the fastest Python serialization and
it's not that surprising since it's the
native Python serialization but you know
you see all these benchmarks for hdf5
and things like that these much more
niche configurable serialization formats
pickle the I should caveat in 3.6 with
the latest pickling version is actually
incredibly fast it's basically doing an
M map direct to disk and then back out
again what you'll you'll see is that
when we trained our model when we called
fit that generates a fitting number of
one every time you call fit you will get
a new new model serialized to disk that
will represent that fitting so you'll
have a bunch of monotonically
incrementing numbers here you'll have a
bunch of results files that are
generated because this is a deep
learning model it actually has weights
which are in that wonderful hdf5 format
that I love so much oh and you've also
got the pickle which will have
everything from your encoders and other
various bits about the model what we're
we save a bunch of statistics about the
test results and the parameters I loss
and how the strains are modeled strained
over history so that we can graph those
later and visualize a bunch of
characteristics and of course we have
logging logging is near and dear to my
heart it solves a lot of debugging
problems it's amazing to me how many
data scientists don't don't really take
the time to set up great logging for
everything that's coming into their
system and going out of their system in
development of course this goes to your
localhost in production this goes to our
logging provider and then we have all of
this credible searchable stuff the cool
thing is that the logging that we get
from training is configured exactly the
same way as the logging that we have
running at inference time so that we can
we can watch our training logs come in
we can watch our inference logs come in
speaking of inference that's the next
slide so this is great we've we've got a
model and we've saved it to our hard
driver to s3 or somewhere the whole the
whole point of having a model is having
a service that runs in production that
the rest of your application can call
and make prediction
and so that when an order is created
that can make an API call to this model
we can predict whether it's going to be
fraudulent or not and we can take some
action in the application at runtime in
real time
some models don't have real time
requirements some models have you know
patched nightly so the only thing they
will do is they will call fit every
night and then they'll call predict on
the whole database every night and we'll
dump all of the predictions to the
database and that's it so that that's
great you use redshift or you use
snowflake we're using both in production
now so we need to add a few more
components to this model so that we can
do inference in real time specifically
we can go back to our extract this is a
newer feature that we're playing with
which is Jinja to templates in our
sequel what we want to do it inference
is we want to scope this query to a
specific delivery we don't want to pull
the whole database we don't want to
connect to redshift which will take
minutes we just want to pull the most
recent up-to-date data from Postgres and
since redshift and Postgres are have
snowflakes all have very similar
dialects this works surprisingly well in
practice we create our template from
Jinja - that has this extra predicate on
the end we'll take our original yet data
from our pipeline we'll expand that so
that it now it takes a delivery ID
parameter and if there's an extra
delivery ID we'll need to pass it to the
template we'll also want to use Postgres
as our data store of choice because now
we're just pulling back a single row
whereas previously we were pulling back
a lot of data from redshift so this this
if you pass a delivery ID to this get
data function we expect millisecond
response time if you don't pass a
delivery ID to this function we expect
it's like 30 minutes run time for the
redshift query to return enough data you
can this is just a little temporary
variable to hold the template
interpolation and then we'll just pass
that to the connection which in these
are the redshift Postgres and it's the
same data frame call
and this time we're gonna pass it raw
sequel set of a file name there are lots
of more options you can pass here and
you can always directly pass
interpolation variables to sequel which
get interpolated safely whether they're
strings or numbers we need to make one
final modification to our model it has
this predict method which is provided by
default but now we want to predict based
on a delivery ID we don't want to
predict based on the default which is a
full data frame typically we will pass
in the full data frame of all of the
data
so our model inference time might not
even have a database connection we'll
just provide it with all of the data
over the wire it'll take that data in as
a data frame it'll run it through the
estimator it's a prediction in this case
we're going to use the pipeline to get
the same data from just for that
delivery ID from the database and it's
going to be using an identical query
which is ensures that we don't have
feature mismatch between training and
prediction time so that's that's a
really hard problem to solve sometimes
you can't always do this sometimes it's
just not feasible you need fact tables
in one that you don't have in the other
but when you can do this it it's follows
to keep it simple stupid principle
pretty well so once once you've done
that you've added your delivery ID
parameter runtime you can fire up a
lower server which is just a little
flask app it will it will automatically
generate endpoints for all of your
models you can call predict on them you
can pass them whatever parameters you
like and it'll give you an answer at
this point you've you're pretty much
ready to go into production with your
model this is a pretty tight
experimentation loop once I've got
something like this running I can go add
you know I think our model is up to 160
features in production now to detect
fraud but without a system like this
that I can continuously rerun my query
continuously evaluate the performance
launch new instances into into tests and
training it takes a lot longer to
iterate if I'm waiting
make one sequel change wait two days
that didn't work one more sequel change
way to days so having sort of continuous
deployment continuous integration and
cloud scalability and deployment for
multiple branches in two different
scenarios before I actually choose one
to commit to master to push and deploy
has greatly accelerated our development
time for machine learning models at
instacart it's basically the finalized
picture of everything I think I've
covered most of the most of the boxes
there just to go over a few of the
Transformers that we've built in-house
that we find we use a lot the geoip is
cool it uses max wines database you get
all kinds of geographic data about
anybody who's visiting your site you can
calculate distance like we went over
date/time and string manipulations are
critical we use these all the time to
generate features from whatever happened
to be stored in the database we can
generate more interesting transformers
like I want to extract the domain from
an email you can have a fairly
complicated or simple reg X to do that I
think the official one is three pages
long or something extracting the area
code from a phone number these are all
fun things that make good features and
machine learning models but if you don't
have them easily accessible it's kind of
a pain to extract that area code from a
free text phone number that may be
internationalized it may have
parenthesis it may not and so a lot of
the time you know data scientists will
skip these kinds of minor feature
engineering improvements which is
unfortunate so we like having a big
library we use US census data that we
can statistically predict the age or sex
or whether you're like a name like mom
in a phone book is a pretty good
indication that you're closely related
to that person so there there's just a
ton of information out there that when
we have a full library we can do much
more advanced feature engineering much
more cheaply encoders are the key
building block that I told you about
they're stateful representations that we
used to do feature engineering I heard
somebody asked earlier about one hot
encoding that's interesting because for
some machine learning algorithms you
have to use one hot encoding when you're
with categorical variables for others
like Karis they have a built-in ability
to handle that in a much more performant
way on the GPU so we have a unique
encoder that will take as many
categoricals as you need and depending
on whether you're using a Karass
estimator or an extra boost esta cater
or sight scikit-learn
what your machine learning model
actually needs if it needs it to be one
hunting coated and expanded into that
sparse format it'll do that if it
doesn't then you saved a lot of
computation things like the glove and
encoder I don't know if you know about
the glove at word embeddings but these
are the ones where if you have a word
like King and you subtract the word man
and you add the word woman then you end
up with the word queen so these are more
cool feature engineering that you can do
so we can actually transform all of the
words in your input into their glove
embeddings know which can be really
useful when you're dealing with things
like product names and etc we we support
everything in scikit-learn next you
boost and caris and tensorflow right now
we're open to adding more libraries but
this is these are the primary toolkits
that our data scientists a machine
learning engineers use an insta card so
that that's pretty much it for me thank
you guys very much question
any questions for Matata
thanks that was really cool you guys do
anything around handling horizontal
scaling once you deploy to production
and how about like a be testing of your
models to make sure that your new models
don't perform worse than your old models
so one of the things that in cover is
that every model has a predict it hasn't
evaluate and has a score function the
score function is something that you're
expected to override and if your score
is lower than the previous training run
you will not be auto deploy to
production so there's there are things
like that typically right now when a
data scientist is doing hyper perimeter
search this is another thing that we
support it's not fully parallelized yet
this is on our roadmap so that you can
you know you want to test and hyper
parameters you'll fire up 50 boxes will
go run all those 50 concurrently collect
the results back but that's not ready
yet we we do have support for multi-gpu
in in terrace which is available which
can it's it's difficult to say that that
always provides linear speed-up with
GPUs I think that the truth is it
depends on the exact characteristics of
your data set and your model but there
are two different strategies that we
support you can toggle them with flags
and see
a software engineering skewed workflow
you know it was clearly designed by
someone who knows Ruby on Rails
scaffolding and unit testing built-in
etc I was wondering how that ends up
interacting with the data scientist your
organization who in my experience often
are more resistant to frameworks like
that and won't work in integrated
environments like our studio or super
notebooks and whatnot yeah you're
exactly right so Jupiter notebooks are a
big part of our data science workflows
those are fully supported and lore a big
part of it is that as soon as you type
more install it will pull down all the
packages it will build you a virtual mm
Python it will install that in your
Jupiter notebook you can fire up your
notebook and have your data science
workflow that you want to have at the
end of the day you're expected to take
the results of your Jupiter notebook
copy and paste those into these cells
once you finalize that and this is
something that we've worked with a lot
on our data science I'm a software
engineer at heart going back many more
years but I think that as long as we we
let them open up the black box and we
give them these windows that they can
completely replace an estimator with a
completely custom tensorflow or pi torch
implementation I guess that's the hot
one now I got a feature request last
week oh so that's cool and we're happy
to do that it's pretty easy it's pretty
seamless all of this ends up in a very
standardized way as long as you conform
to a few key milestones which data
scientists have been like fine I'll do
that for you kind of a follow up to the
last question so the encoders idea is
really cool do you have any kind of
tools or tricks to speed up the extracts
part or like to encode that so I am
probably the weakest eighth engineer in
this room I I write my redshift query
and I expect that it works we we have an
amazing data engineering team who could
probably give you these tips and tricks
of use a disk key or make sure you have
your sort key right but for the most
part we write a lot of sequel we tune it
by hand we test it against our systems
we have experts in-house that because we
are in a monolithic repository every
every sequel statement that gets issued
against a database is tagged with the
code line number that it's coming from
and so our database monitors will then
flag high CPU usage queries and then
you'll you'll work with an expert in
that system on what are you actually
trying to do and how can we do this
better sometimes the answer is like well
you have to do a whole bunch more
engineering you have to put this in
Redis you have to pre calculate features
that's hard that takes a lot of work we
try not to do that we try to do the
simplest thing that can work which is
have really really large Redis or
snowflake deployments
how do you use how do you ensure that
the data that you use for training from
redshift and radar that you use for
curing scoring from Postgres or
identical and to how do you do you
ensure that the feature encoders that
you use for training and the feature
encouraged use for scoring are also the
exactly the same given that you use two
different languages one with Python for
training and probably Ruby for scoring
no so all of the scoring happens us all
intersect much first all the scoring
happens in python using the same
encoders it's all it's all one thing
it's pickled it son pickled it never
changes and so that's why the flask
server gives us an HTTP API we actually
have our own RPC service that we use
that goes over RabbitMQ internally but
flask is so that we can make this a nice
external open source project your first
question can you say that one more time
okay so what happens typically is our
Postgres database is replicated in many
read replicas which is sort of our first
line of attack that then gets replicated
directly to redshift or snowflake and so
we we try to use identical tables that
have had one-to-one replication that's
dangerous because what you may have
historically in redshift so if if
something gets updated after the fact
like let's say that we notify the visit
IP address whenever there's fraud the
model will now look at all these fraud
that'll see no I P addresses like oh
this is so easy right but then at
prediction time so that's something that
you you just have to be careful about
you have to do the data science
diligence and typically it's really
obvious when somebody comes seem like I
can detect 99.99% of fraud I was like
well maybe we should you know verify
this a little bit more before we roll it
out in production everything we roll out
gets a be tested that's the ultimate
answer of checking the quality of
something if it it doesn't matter how
good your loss looks in any graph if
you're not actually impacting business
metrics
so at the end of the day we can roll it
out in an a/b test and see see if it
works and we typically do a/b testing we
have blog posts it's very hard to a/b
test logistical businesses that involve
large integer programming problems where
you have to come up with a universal
optimal solution you can't solve half of
the universe at once so that's
interesting but that's we generally
scale up our a/b tests from you know 1%
exposure to 10% over time and roll out
that way
all right Oh more questions so cool
system I'm curious about the speed so
like how what's the fastest you can kind
of deliver predictions in with because
you're serializing pipelines in did I
get deserialized and kind of stick in
memory or yeah so the the timers and the
loggers were actually the biggest
bottleneck on speed until we measured
our timers with more timers so you know
I have a 300 line query that I run
against our Postgres read replicas takes
about 22 milliseconds to aggregate all
of the data for a single fraud query
that's the average if a user has a long
history can take up to a second we're
lucky because we can implement a timeout
there because if users have long history
they're much less likely to be
committing fraud so there are some
cheats that you can you can play with I
think that if you're talking about deep
learning inference can be super fast
again you're talking about in
milliseconds 50 milliseconds I think is
the prediction speed of a model that has
about 10 million parameters for this
particular problem and that's actually
an ensemble with XG boost which has a
few hundred trees so all in all this is
these are well below the one one second
cutoff that we typically reserved for
RPC calls out during a customer
transaction
our RPC setup oh it's not common I think
that one day we would like to open
source it it's a Ruby and Python RPC
service that works over rabbitmq so it
does both pub/sub and it does both
direct calls so U and Q your call into
rabbit and you can either have listeners
that listen for that published event or
you can have consumers that will consume
that event and then post a reply back
onto rabbit and then it will be reverse
consumed for RPC call so it's a nice
universal
you